ladies and gentlemen Tim Chang and Rishi
guard how are you doing
we are last thing stand between you and
lunch so we're going to try to talk fast
and give you something useful maybe it
off the beaten track
yeah send you off to lunch feeling nice
and epic have your appetites be full
shoot it down yeah sure
um so I'm Tim Chang a partner with
Mayfield fund we're actually one of the
earliest venture capital firms here in
the valley were based down in Menlo Park
some of our companies as was mentioned
include lyft you're taking a lyft
Poshmark
class Pass Elon Musk Solar City company
I recently sold called moat to Oracle so
we do a lot of enterprise and consumer
and it's my pleasure to welcome our
newest partner Rishi Garg who was a
early senior exec at square and Twitter
he also himself did his hustle as a
entrepreneur before including big skins
prior to that at Google and MTV in other
places oh thanks him and thanks also to
Sam and John for putting together such
an awesome group of people and a great
conference that helped you guys are
having a great time right yeah give him
a hand
my first hump of Tom and amazing to see
how far this has come into the short
period of time you know just to build on
what Tim said you know Mayfield's backed
about 600 companies in this history and
over time kind of learned a lot about
founders and myself at the founder and
and with Tim being an entrepreneur his
background as well and all the founders
we've seen you kind of see a lot of the
same characteristics and a lot of them
were covered by Miguel just now some of
the elements of the founder journey that
are so special to what it's like to be a
founder and that's kinda what we wanted
to talk about today because the more we
reflected on some of those ideas with
Sam and John it sort of led to let this
talk here so what do we mean by this
what what do we mean by founder
psychology or the founder journey the
founders get a lot of advice on how to
like manage your company and how to run
the company and how to think about
strategy but one thing that's not as
talked about is how intimate the
experiences of being the founder of a
company it is not just a job it's not
just a place you go to work
it becomes the most deeply embedded
part of your identity how many founders
might identify with that out there
anybody like sort of feel that if you
started a company before it's rare that
a hundred percent of the founder hands
don't go up on that one because it's
something that's sort of you really
believe in if you're going to do that
you put your all into it and the thing
is all the good things and bad things by
your psychology end up getting
manifested in the culture of your
company and the culture of your company
into becoming the factor towards your
success that matters the most as we've
seen over time and so that makes it a
really important topic for us as we
think about not just advising founders
but also as investors we're item like
with all the companies that you see it's
not really this is one of the most
important elements that we care about
yeah founder attributes your
personalities who you are as peoples
actually what we talk about most buying
closed doors after the pitch usually
people think it's business plan quality
technology stack that kind of stuff that
is actually traits around founder grit
for lack of a better word you know that
sort of fortitude that sort of
willingness to go all the way walk
through walls but also things that are
softer self-awareness mindfulness if you
will and even authenticity and
vulnerability those are things we are
looking for all the time we're looking
for clues of those in how you tell your
story how you treat your co-founders how
you think about your customers and most
of all with that an example is when
people are trying to answer questions a
lot of times folks feel like they have
to have every answer button-down but
that's a big tell right there one of the
best ways to build trust with investors
is knowing when to say I don't know as
opposed to try to craft an answer
showing you know everything because the
truth is we don't every startups an
experiment there's so much that's
unknown and it's almost more important
to know what you don't know and then
bonus points if you have a way to test
it and how to build sort of some
hypotheses and how many of the founders
you've backed are hatched fully formed
from an AI gets perfect CEOs none and I
think to a tee every single company
we've ever backed whatever their exit
was I was successful resembled nothing
in the original pitch that's right and
and and when I was I was very lucky to
be part of two really interesting
companies the last ten years
and Twitter and for me that exact point
that Tim's talking about where you see
the evolution of a founder over time was
really brought home because I got to
work for two companies back were founded
by Jack Dorsey it was really interesting
because when I got to square sort of at
the end of 2011 one thing that struck me
was how singular the culture was its
square it was focused on a few things
that made a really different it was
extremely collaborative everything was
an open office framework the most
openness of offices it was every part
about our business was about pixel
perfection it was about generating trust
because we were carrying billions of
dollars of transactions so everything
from the way that we designed our
Hardware reader to every single part of
the user experience for onboarding in
the app all of that was it had to be
excellent all the time we pushed
ourselves in that way
we were extremely structured every
meeting the way that we reviewed the
activities of the company and it was
also very top-down a lot of the power
was sort of concentrated with a top tier
through folks so even as an executive
you sort of felt that a few years after
I was early as Square I ended up being
recruited over to Twitter to run
corporate development and there I got
kind of a shock I kind of realized how
much Square was a reaction to Twitter in
some way from a cultural standpoint and
showed the growth that the founder had
gone through because Twitter was much
more like an ad hoc receipt Twitter was
as a company in terms of the inner
workings of it as protein and
democratized and occasionally Messi as
Twitter as a product loss you know we we
sort of made decisions in the hallways
there wasn't a ton of sort of high-level
structure in terms of the frequency of
our meetings and the reviews and stuff
like that but it all kind of it all kind
of worked create this amazing platform
and so much of what I realized then was
that Jack's journey as a founder and his
potential for growth was a reason that
both Twitter and Square was successful
because obviously the way that power was
consolidated and the focus on getting
everything just right at square was
reaction some the experiences that were
had a twitter and both of those were
amazing companies but one thing I've
admired the most about Jack over time is
a
under a lot of the founders have worked
with over the years and visited over the
years is that they have this capacity
for personal growth which is really
really hard right I mean you've had some
experiences I think as well the founders
you've worked with yeah you know the
point we're hammering here is that
startups companies are basically
extension of the founders personality
values persona all those sorts of things
Zappos and Tony Hsieh their CEO is a
good example Tony's a friend we've been
to Burning Man many times and I was
struck by how much inspiration he took
from Burning Man and brought back into
his own company culture to make an
otherwise miserable business of low
margin shoe selling online at minimum
wage feel like an amazing place to work
it was imbued in their values when you
walk in the lobby on their values board
are things not just about creativity but
about being weird and wacky and how
every pod of every table is like a
Burning Man camp for your there to craft
your own identity as a team
self-expression is imbued throughout
open-mindedness and it was kind of
amazing to see just how much fun you
could take an otherwise shitty minimum
hour minimum wage our job feel with that
right culture at play and it started
from I think Tony totally so then the
question is okay if you're if who you
are the founder is completely imbued
into the culture and the everyday
experience of your company then follow
that you'd want to grow and have in many
weapons at your disposal as possible to
become the best founder you can be and
manage some of those goods and Bad's
that we all have within us so what are
some of the things that you've seen Tim
that work really well to help do that
especially some of the stuff maybe that
a lot of founders might not naturally
think about we always talk about the
founder grid right and this x-factor and
I want to share a few notes with you
kind of I've observed and some of these
might seem a little off the beaten path
but I'm hoping they'll be helpful for
you you know we always look for founders
who are great managers and leaders but
the truth is being a really good leader
starts with managing yourself and so I
kind of think of this sort of fitness
stack if you will you know how to take
care your body you exercise you do yoga
but there's also the notion of wellness
at all levels your body your mind your
emotions even your soul your spirit if
you will and so we think a lot about
how founders can manage your energy
levels your mindfulness even your sleep
when it comes to energy and food I'm a
big fan of looking how to optimize you
know the things you eat what you don't
eat the supplements use those sorts of
things there is a rising awareness for
things like nootropics and smart drugs
I'm a big fan of personal user of things
like neutral box and bulletproof from
Dave Asprey fasting is a big wave these
days on how you sort of manage you know
your caloric intake and expenditures so
intermittent fasting is one I've seen a
lot of founders use to keep their
calories sort of in a certain cycle and
have their mental awareness acutely
tuned throughout the day mindfulness and
meditation although it sounds a bit whoo
it can make a huge difference and what
for me that is whatever vehicle you use
whether it's apps like headspace at home
going to meditation retreats doing yoga
micro dosing whatever it is that you
find it's a way to train yourself on how
to respond intentionally to all the
stress hitting you throughout the day as
opposed to honestly most of us are
reacting to fear and crisis 90% of the
time it's an emotional reaction and face
it startups are nothing but fire drill
existential threat every day in and out
it's just stressing you out throughout
so anything you do to kind of establish
a baseline so you're responding
intentionally as opposed that emotional
reaction is a big deal
and lastly we kind of idolize this
notion of like you know you sleep when
you're dead and it's all about the
hustle and work hard but God you know
all those years I wish I didn't believe
that because you never get those hours
of sleep back you can't just sleep when
you're dead
sleep turns out to be a secret weapon in
digesting all the things throughout the
day that's happened and also coming up
with non-obvious ideas that wouldn't
have struck you so as nuts as it sounds
don't skip out on your seven eight hours
of sleep a day it makes a big difference
even for your creative process and your
productivity
yeah there's yeah right
I think a lot of people feel the feel
that stress out of the audience and are
really excited that they sort of can
have support in pursuing a healthful
lifestyle there's this great blog post
by a coach named edy Batista who writes
about this evolution that occurs between
being a worker being and not being
employee versus being a founder or CEO
which is that when you're when you're
kind of working for somebody else your
job is just to get the work done most of
the time but when you become a CEO or a
founder the job is to present you and
that's why it's such a heavy burden on
you that's why it's so deeply involved
in your identity but if you're going to
present you and your beliefs about the
world and the mission that you're on
then you have to protect the health of
that asset to protect that health of you
which is why the physicality is so
important why sleep is so important
another thing that's starting to get
talked about a lot but isn't still right
now in the valley is mental illness and
not just melt there's two things sort of
mental illness
which is that these pressure sometimes
can uncover some real pain for us and
that those need to be dealt with on a
professional level but also the idea of
D stigmatizing the idea of help and that
can be through a lot of different angles
part of it's do coaching which I'm happy
to say is increasingly common amongst
honors in fact of Mayfield we're
instituting policies where we're going
to overtime sort of ask that all or
highly encourage all of our portfolio
companies to get coaches so that they
can get additional perspectives on how
they can grow and develop over time and
I strongly encourage founders to do that
almost everyone that I meet regardless
what they're at may feel because I know
it helps everyone has a coach Michael
Jordan had a coach and they could be
incredibly valuable to you having an
advisory board of informal people that
you actually trust to get advice from as
opposed to one or two people only but to
really build some relationships and
invest in building those relationships
because of those key moments that you
decide to those key Mobile's where you
need that kind of help
and then finally actually getting
therapy the sounder stressors are really
really strong and I can't tell you how
many founders have told me that when
they've actually disclosed that they've
sought help from a great therapist as
part of the process that they've
actually found it to help enormous Lee
with the burdens of being a founder
because those burdens are very very real
so then the question is asking now
you're doing all this
to actually make yourself better on your
journey to becoming a better founder by
manifesting that in your culture and
that's really important what do you do
when you get to work what are some ways
to actually start to showcase that
growth of that capability within work
and I think one of the most important
things that we've seen is how founders
approach mission vision and values right
them yeah after you get to take care of
yourself and you're really self-aware
you can bring that to work and kind of
shape the team in the culture around you
and this is important because we always
talk about the what and the how of our
hustle but not always the why and the
why matters a lot
I think the why keeps you going and I
know it sounds fluffy to write down your
mission and vision statement but it's
actually those things to keep you going
when is falling apart around you
which it always does um
this exercise is also kind of a force
multiplier in helping you really just
know what your true north is and I think
if you really know your purpose of what
you're doing I think it'll help you let
go of your fear of failure and maybe
over time even learn to surrender that
attachment to the outcome what's going
to happen this is big to me because
statistically most startups will fail
but if you know why you're building what
you're building there's a lot of value
in that and it's going to create benefit
in the world anyway so you know for me I
want to take a moment to thank all of
you for doing the hustle you're doing
regardless of the outcome of it it's an
experiment that needs to be run and
there's some contribution to the world
that you're building that we're all
going to learn from and so that's why I
think the vision part is really
important because it's the why behind
the hustle yeah and if you haven't if
you haven't already spent time really
articulating that your what your mission
is and really spending time on it when I
was a founder the thing I thought was
the most frou frou thing to focus on and
it turned out to be the only thing that
mattered in fact at what I was asked
where we there was something that we
implemented that turned out to be so
different when it came to this topic but
I just wanted to share with you because
I could have always been so impressed by
it it's the idea that you use your
values to make decisions so the way that
we do value the square was that Jack
sort of helped us articulate help the
firt help the company articulate four
core values we called them the four
corners and then the way that we would
kind of judge whether or not those were
are adequately reflecting the words were
adequately affecting who we are and why
we came to work every day is whether or
not we would use those words in meetings
to make decisions because that's what
value should be right the famous of the
I think the values for Enron were like
you know accountability leadership
excellence integrity or something like
that I mean it's like when you actually
use values that are part of who you are
and then you start to make decisions
about them they really argue about and
that's always been a great North Star
for me as I work with founders on on how
to get those down on paper it's it's
kind of it's it's work that always feels
like it's less important to something
else but it turns out a lot of times I
think to be the most important thing
there's one other thing that gets
overlooked a lot and it's again starting
to get written about but it's co-founder
relationships because this is very
lonely as a job to be a founder and most
companies are half the company's roughly
have co-founding relationships and those
are as important as any important
relationship you'll ever have I mean
they're there you spend more time with
your co-founder than you do in a
marriage and yet it's amazing how few
times founders actually spend time
working on that relationship explicitly
and found it about standing
relationships together often end up
being certainly if not more successful
though they probably are they certainly
enjoy that journey more and can
disconnect from the outcome as Tim just
says a great example in our portfolio
I've actually left where the first
investors in left one of the really
compelling things when you when you saw
a list sort of back in the day but it
still Zimride was the relationship
between John and Logan and that
tightness that bond the the effort they
made towards our relationship which
persists to this day and we think is
part of the reason they've been able to
weather the storm and continue to grow
in a really changing environment again
back to the importance of coaching and
even therapy same techniques for marital
therapy probably applied for co-founders
right but I think we're out of time so I
just wanted to leave you with those
parting thoughts and I hope those are
helpful and again like I said some of
these come off as woowoo or touchy-feely
but they actually are the things that
kind of matter in the end even behind
the KPIs and metrics that's right the
the you know I joined may fold about
here
and the reason I did it was the this is
a unique time in the Silicon Valley
where a few people are creating a lot of
impact and so the more that founders can
sort of spend their time on building
themselves to make that impact the
ripple effects for positivity are pretty
dramatic thanks a lot take care of
yourself guys
[Applause]